[Música]
hola hoy les vengo hablar de una
situación que yo muchas veces he vivido
y seguramente también ustedes muchas
veces han discutido con sus papás
argumentos van y argumentos vienen
mientras ustedes intentan con todas sus
fuerzas que ellos vean su punto y justo
cuando parece que sus padres agotaron su
último recurso de convencimiento y ya no
pueden rebatir su último y contundente
argumento ellos les dan un fatalista e
irrefutable cuando crezcas me vas a
entender un golpe mortal ya no hay nada
que puedas decir o hacer tus padres
entraron en la mentalidad de así es y
punto porque es tan difícil que tus
papás te entiendan pero para ser justos
también deberíamos preguntarnos por qué
es tan difícil que tú entiendas a tus
papás pareciera que hubiese un abismo
entre tu mente y la de ellos y es que en
realidad así es hay un abismo real y se
llama la brecha generacional
esta es la distancia que hay entre una
generación y otra no solamente en años
también en costumbres creencias valores
cultura y conducta
nuestros padres nos llevan en promedio
unos 20 o 25 años cuando ellos tenían
nuestra edad el mundo solía ser
diferente bueno muy diferente las las
costumbres la cultura y los valores de
su época se quedaron grabados en ellos
de la misma manera que nosotros los
jóvenes nos estamos definiendo cada día
por los tiempos que estamos viviendo
precisamente hoy y tal vez algún día nos
sorprendamos cuando de nuestras bocas
salgan las mismas palabras que hoy no se
enojan tanto cuando seas grande ya me
comprenderás y veamos en nuestros
futuros hijos adolescentes los mismos
ojos que se elevan al techo en un acto
de frustración
cuando los adultos nos tratan de
corregir nos molestamos o no estamos de
acuerdo con esto un ejemplo en mi caso
es mi pelea con mi papá pero no es
cualquier pelea es una pelea diaria por
los hábitos y la forma de vida que yo
llevo un ejemplo mío soy constante de
algún aparato tecnológico o de la
computadora
mi papá piensa que es una pérdida de
tiempo o que inclusive la tecnología se
está comiendo a mi cerebro y aunque yo
la use para trabajos o tareas él lo toma
de manera negativa ya que él creció
haciendo sus tareas a mano o
investigando en libros casi puedo oír su
voz en este momento cuando yo tenía tu
edad
verdaderamente tenía que esforzarme por
hacer mis trabajos y tareas tenía que ir
a la biblioteca y pasar toda la tarde
investigando en libros los jóvenes de
ahora no tienen que hacer ningún
esfuerzo se dedican a copiar y pegar de
internet y por más que yo trate de
celebra en papá que la tecnología cambió
al mundo y que ahora ese tiempo lo
podemos usar para otras cosas no logró
cambiar su manera de pensar y muchas
veces acabamos enojados y sin lograr
establecer una verdadera
comunicación es importante mencionar que
mis papás me llevan casi 40 años de
diferencia
la brecha son dos generaciones y si tú
tienes problemas de comunicación con una
brecha de 20 años imagínate lo que es
hacerte entender cuando la brecha es el
doble
los tiempos han cambiado sí y no sólo
por la llegada de la tecnología ha
habido movimientos que incluyen la
eliminación de visiones negativas o
discriminativas como el sometimiento
machismo sexismo por mencionar algunas
nuestros padres han vivido en un mundo
de crisis económicas constantes en el
país cambios políticos monumentales en
el mundo y rediseño de la familia y sus
dinámicas cuando ellos eran jóvenes las
familias hoy a ser más numerosas y menos
madres trabajan fuera de casa la vida
parece transcurrir más lentamente y
según dicen algunos hasta se disfrutaba
más
pero que los jóvenes que los padres se
quejan amargamente los jóvenes no es
cosa nueva ya desde antes era común que
los adultos se quejaran demasiado
aristóteles escribe en su retórica que
los jóvenes son arrogantes porque aún no
han sido humillados por la vida creen
que lo saben todo y están tan seguros de
ello pues bien no es por contra real
gran sabio griego pero algo así
podríamos decir los padres los padres
son arrogantes porque ya fueron
humillados por la vida creen que lo
saben todo y están tan seguros de ello
que ni siquiera escuchan a sus hijos es
el cuento de nunca acabar
pero aunque yo sé que quizá nunca
convenza en papá que la tecnología
cambió al mundo y que ahora las cosas
han cambiado demasiado pues no cambia
viva para siempre será 40 años mayor que
yo y eso no lo podremos cambiar jamás
nuestras mentes siempre tendrán que
sobreponerse a la distancia en los
tiempos las ideas las convicciones pero
si bien las mentes pueden estar a años
de distancia mi papá y yo estamos
cercanos muy cercanos cada vez que
hablamos cada vez que él intenta hacerme
ver su punto
y cada vez que yo trato de hacer que él
reconozca mis argumentos nos acercamos
más nos conocemos más si no en las
mentes en el corazón hablar y discutir
con papá significa que él no importa y
que yo le importo así que gracias papá
por sacarme de quicio tantas veces sé
que eres realmente en tus convicciones
porque me quieres y honestamente te
preocupas por mí a veces demasiado eso
sí muchas veces el tiempo me enseñó que
en muchos de tus ideas tenía razón hay
otras en las que todavía estamos
trabajando te pido que nos tengamos
paciencia y que estemos siempre
dispuesto a escucharnos el uno al otro y
que nunca nunca dejemos de hablar
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]